Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so we finally
got Spider-Man confirmed for avengers infinity
war.
So I'll explain that, but I wanted to do a
list for the characters that we did know about
so this is going to be top 50.
There are a lot of characters new round of
the Spider-Man giveaway starts now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video I announce winners
at the end be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything of the big
news is the Tom Holland confirmed that he
was going to be in infinity war he been left
off the list that everybody's been posting.
So there was a question like a maybe they
won't include in but I don't think any of
us believe that I mean you gotta put Spider-Man
infinity war, so top 50 characters that are
going to be in infinity war.
I tried to group some these together starting
with the really big ones that are brand-new
and then the supporting characters, the classic
roster, so number 50*the list up Spider-Man
Tom Holland said this is part of the interview
that he gave it's they who convinced Marvel
talking about Robert Downey Junior and Chris
Evans to be sure that I was the right person
for you and trust three films over the next
four years including Avengers infinity war.
So that's a bit of a broken sentence.
But as a translation of the Italian interview
where he basically says that Robert Downey
Junior and Chris Evans really went to bat
for him because Spider-Man was going to be
so important for the next three movies the
three films that he is referring to our Captain
America Civil War.
Spider-Man homecoming in Avengers infinity
war, we know that he's actually signed on
for more Spider-Man SQL since then but he's
just talking about those three films in this
interview next on the list.
Doctor strange we all know that he is now
the de facto magic user that they'll go to
for help.
He knows little about the infinity gems.
He is very well read, so is already helping
Thor with his Ragnarok problem.
So he seemed Dormammu he's been to other dimensions
he wields one of the infinity gems he's going
to be super important to the avengers then
there's Wong who comes hand-in-hand with Doctor
strange next one is Baron more to not really
a main character of infinity war but so big
you have to touch base with them characters
that you'll see in the film that they'll touch
on it will be big Easter eggs that might not
necessarily be on screen is much as the classic
avengers the bigger actors.
So next one is Captain Marvel big introduction
this is supposed to be her introduction.
Spider-Man style with a lot of her back story
is going to be left for the Captain Marvel
solo film then there's the winter soldier
he is in a deep-freeze right now.
So let the thought amount because he's every
bit as capable as Captain America when Santos
comes calling you need as much help as possible.
Nick fury is back in if you're wondering why
he hasn't been in the last couple Marvel films
it's mostly because of contractual disputes
with Samuel Jackson.
He's a very expensive person they chose to
spend their money hiring other actors to do
other characters they felt were more important
of the story next one is Loki just like Doctor
strange also has a lot of information on Panos
that he can help everyone with definitely
has to come to terms with the idea that he
doublecrossed they Enos and he's got to try
and survive that man of the hour is Panos
if you haven't read the infinity gauntlet
or infinity quests storyline from the comics
is basically him assembling the gems forming
the gauntlet and then a racing half of all
life in the universe in the avengers all the
heroes trying to fix that.
He's probably the most important character
in that movie, so numbers 41 through 36 is
basically his forces the black order that
should Towery that are left over and any other
space Army that he brings to bear.
So he does have a lot of followers.
We met one before the other was a member of
the black order that was killed by Ronan back
during the first guardians of the galaxy fell.
So will probably find out who is helping him
because he will be all by himself, Peter Dinklage
from game of thrones was actually just announced
as I was making this list, so I got to include
him just in time Rob life filled with like
the first person to say he's pit was an important
figure with Adam warlock in the infinity gauntlet
storyline, but I don't actually think that
Peter Dinklage will play Pip he is supposed
to be an important character in both of the
next avengers sequels speaking of the guardians
pretty much every main Guardian character
is coming including star Lord who hasn't returned
to earth in a long time.
So it'll be the first time he's actually interacted
with other humans in a long long time Camorra
nebula daughters of Sandoz family reunion
rocket root who may or may not still be baby
Groot, it depends on how big he grows by the
end of the guardians film, but for most of
that film he supposed to stay that same size
and then of course tracks, but we haven't
heard anything about mantis new big character
in guardians to, showing up so I'm not expecting
her in the film, but then here we get to like
the supporting characters, we haven't seen
in a while.
So Pepper Potts will touch on with her.
She will be a big part of the film she is
currently running Stark tech for Tony while
he runs the avengers or tries to run the avengers
Jane Foster Betty Ross is supposed to come
back.
There's a rumor that Liv Tyler will come back.
Even though they recast the hold since the
last time she played that character then there's
thunderbolt Ross who's the Defense Secretary
very important government figure Sharon Carter
who is very close to Captain America's character
now Colson is finally rumored to be coming
back ghostwriter is a really cool character
that supposed to have at least a brief appearance
he's too cool for you to leave out and he's
just as powerful as the hold.
If not more powerful.
He was actually Doctor strange to theorize
during world war hold that ghostwriter was
one of the few entities that was around and
available they could take down world breaker
Hulk Maria Hill also rumored to appear on
May is a little more certain just coming hand-in-hand
with Peter Parker, Hank him because of ant
Man in the WASP.
Speaking of which Antman and the wasp and
ant Man is a very important avenger already
the wasp is going to be a very important character
she's not can have a relatively big appearance
to the second avengers film in the ant Man
in the wasp Solo movie.
But she will have a presence during infinity
war.
Even though Evangeline Lilly the actress is
said that she won't be wearing the wasp costume
until the ant Man in the wasp movie.
The other new main characters.
Of course Black Panther very important.
Everett Ross, which is a Black Panther character
will see him again during the Black Panther
movie vision and scarlet which you also kind
of come hand-in-hand now war machine who is
slowly recovering from his accident Valkyrie
who's in of the Thor character the we haven't
met yet.
She's really important.
They will be a couple of characters from each
of the Avengers films to make guest appearances
Valkyrie just like the new biggest character
that were gonna meet then, the classic roster
Captain America who still doesn't have the
shield, but I think we all expect them to
pick the shield back up during infinity war.
Just because the threat is so great the whole
post Ragnarok who will have gone through almost
an entire film in hold for so banner will
be much more in tune with the big green guy
they'll have a much more straightforward agreement
between the two of them reborn Thor baptized
by fire now will be like room and King Thor
that he will be more actualize more powerful,
more assured of himself much more prepared
to become king after Odin a much less cynical
version of Iron Man thanks to Peter Parker's
influence.
I feel like his excitement is going to be
infectious he will help Iron Man loosen up
before infinity war.
We have Hawkeye in black widow and then rounding
out the top five is the defenders characters.
They said a lot about them not being in the
film.
The way people expected.
So don't be surprised if there like really
big Easter eggs in they're not getting a lot
of screen time but daredevil Jessica Jones
iron fist Luke Cage in the punisher the list
of 50 is really just preliminary.
This is going to be 66+ characters so we can
amend this later on when we confirm other
people, but a lot of those extra characters
are really just background people people whose
names that you'll see on list won't actually
have like functional lines or dialogue in
the movie.
So when they say 66+ characters are in the
film really there's gonna be a fraction of
that that you'll see on screen at any given
time.
So don't worry.
It just when they say there's a lot of characters
in the film, it sounds like it's gonna be
a mess.
It will not be a mess.
Don't worry if there's any Spider-Man or infinity
war videos the you guys want me to do just
let me know in the comments are for the other
Marvel films say congratulations to this week's
Spider-Man giveaway winner Joshua Sifuentes
you and a $20 comics all and she giftcard
be sure to private message me on the back
and my channel so I can get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video, they just announced a whole bunch of
Star Wars episode eight plot teasers.
So I'll be doing a video for that next is
a whole much awesome stuff happening this
week.
A whole bunch of stuff is coming back really
suit is gonna be great while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here to catch
up on is that she'll learn about the Doctor
strange dark old stuff that they been doing
and you can click here to learn about why
everyone's freaking out about that in the
Justice league thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight!